we've got marie on the line
marie what is on your mind
yes hi thank you for taking my call it's
a pleasure to speak to both of you well
thank you ma'am
um you're welcome i listen every day
um i have a relationship problem
that i'm trying to break up with
seven credit cards that i recently
i recently paid off so i'm i have no
credit card debt
good and i just i just got off the phone
with city cards to close the account
okay and the ladies like are you sure
you want to close i've been with them
for 18
plus years wow marie they're not your
friends
they're not in there i'm like oh my god
i said i have to sleep on it you know
okay
hurry listen listen if you had cancer
for 18 years and you went into the
doctor and they said i can solve this
today would you say let me sleep on it
i've gotten to really love this giant
tumor that i carry around with me
that's poisoning my heart and my life
and my relationships
no so hard marie i have to know
after 18 years of being in the i am that
debt score
credit card gang fan club what caused
you to get serious about paying them off
um well
i recently lost the house
then i was renting and then that
property was sold so i had to move again
and my credit was
awful so i couldn't get a mortgage so i
took money out of my ira which i just
got done paying the
irs income tax on that money
um so i i i bought the house
cash paid for
so marie what's in your what what is
what's the
this is me being serious what's the fear
what are you scared of i guess the fear
is is
you know old habits it's not all
happening
what's the fear needing there you go
leading the card
yeah do you have an emergency maybe
needing
i i i only have a thousand dollars
right now okay um i'm not a jet except
for a personal loan for 7
000 which i plan to pay off by what's
your income
i'm retired so i get
uh pension and social security which is
two thousand seven hundred forty dollars
a month
okay so you've got a paid off house
you've got a paid off house i've
paid off i paid off 10
10 including the irs and since february
up until uh what july
15th i had to pay my taxes ten thousand
six hundred
one dollars okay well listen between the
irs and credit cards
i'm proud of you now i have seven cards
to close right
you're gonna have to listen you're gonna
have to stand the ground okay marina i
don't know if in your history
were you ever married at all twice
okay did you date a lot too
yeah did you ever date anybody that was
crazy
yeah do you remember no hold on a minute
do you remember trying to break up with
them
okay you remember that it wasn't easy
right because they would keep coming
wouldn't they
yeah yeah it wasn't easy it was very
difficult yeah
i'm telling you this because you trying
to close out these credit cards
it's like you trying to get away from
crazy but here's the deal you don't
you don't just tiptoe away from crazy
you run
and i mean all out track shoe
down low running in the wind
okay you get away from it and that's
exactly what you're gonna have to do
with these credit cards
they're gonna offer you to drop the
interest rate they're gonna act like
they're your best friend like they give
you a kidney if you needed it
you and i both know it's a lie listen to
me keep the clarity of mine open
shut them down get it out of your life
it's paid off
you have a home outright you've put
yourself on the path for different
psychologically you're going to have to
get ready it is scary
because you've never done it before but
can also be awesome
you don't know you've never done it
before trust us
you going on this path you're not going
to regret it and i'm going to tell you
you close out the credit cards you move
forward if two years down the road your
life just
is incomplete because you don't have it
then go get another one it's the wrong
day gone move to take i almost said a
different word i'm glad it didn't
but you don't need to so so chris let me
ask you this this is a baby steps
question
you're going to learn me because you're
a math guy i'm i've got a paid off house
i've got no debts i i in february on a
fixed income
i've still managed to manage to pay off
10 grand i've got these seven empty
cards
out there i've fallen in love with them
they're beautiful
i love them in my life they feel good in
my wallet but i only have a thousand
dollar emergency fund
do you want somebody getting that three
months before they cut all these up
or do you want someone getting six
months before you cut all these i want
you you've paid them off
cut them up close them down and get them
out of your life you have the thousand
dollars there
so that means if something were to
happen and this is where people will
take me john
well chris you know what if i need a car
repair you have the thousand dollars
see what we're trying to do is to break
the break the debt cycle
it's a psychological cycle and a grip
as well as this emotional tie and i
the lady told me once she goes chris
i've been a member of american express
since 87
and i go what did it get you she goes
what do you mean i go well it says it on
the car she goes i know but i belong
i said to them that's right
right oh and she looked at me and a
little lip got quivering right because
she
she she had identified with that that
that was her
that's not you chris i've never even
thought about it what a devious
psychological
psychological move oh a member like you
belong to the what i love dead club
brotherhood of visa yeah i mean it's
just it's and so
helping people shift their mindset on
that you shut them things down get it
out of your life
uh you know marie what you've done is
with a home outright
uh i want you to build up the emergency
fund then begin to invest be aware
just don't go backwards honey i mean
that's the thing it's at this time and
age where people are at home
we're one or two clicks away from boxers
showing up and overspending and busting
your budget so
just remain clear and calm you can get
there john
from a psychological standpoint of
helping people to do something they've
never done before
right what have you found i know you've
worked with people
police officers i mean you know you
allow all kinds of situations
but psychologically what do we have to
do for ourselves in order to make change
happen
i think we have to a say i'm done with
this
you've got to have a commitment yeah
number two you've got to have a place
you got to have a picture of where
you're headed
no you've got it's gotta be clear not
just i wanna make more money right not
just i need a better job
what does that look like and most people
cannot answer this question
what do you want what do you want like
well you know what no
no what do you want i want more money
what do you want and most people
don't even have a psychology for what
peace feels like
what not being owned feels like what not
being indebted to somebody feels like
being joyful feels like
and so the third thing is you gotta have
somebody with you you gotta have a
community to walk with you
because doing new things hard means
you're gonna stumble a lot you're gonna
fall down
and it just is easy to lay there
sometimes and you gotta have somebody
pick you up you gotta have somebody text
you in the morning you have someone
that's gonna call you
you've got to say no more here's what
this is gonna look like and i gotta get
somebody to walk with me or two people
or five people or ten people no
no i'm married a long time i've been
with the same woman for even longer
and i've gotta have a marriage counselor
every once in a while i've got to have
somebody that i know is going to ask me
about my marriage
i've got to have several people that are
going to ask me how i'm being as a
husband and they're going to
kick my butt when i when i screw up and
they're going to pick my butt up when i
fall down
and they're going to cheer me i want to
do well right yeah no that's right
that's the men's group i've got
we get in there we talk about emotions
and the feelings uh-oh yeah dude but
just getting real because you you look
at this you realize i'm feeling them and
i got them
so what are they doing they're either
running me or i'm running them right i
get a chance to make a choice
i'm grown and i choose better that's a
decision i'm making every day
all people stay with us we're having fun
this is the dave ramsey show